you guys this is Pat from Sydney
Australia this is Pat today patent
straight out to the Brisbane Lions were
on an insane win streak hey what's up
foes first of all thank everybody's and
I'm just a lot here from Australia I
just hated to show some love and
appreciation for cat to go in the back
gang beat damn he said you should be
mindful I got a question for you all but
he said super serious and creepy
whatever there's a deal that alright
have a casual sexual arrangement with
yeah dog with friends but witnesses on
Tom's and then she's introduced me to
another one of her friends who's he's
really cute not I think I I've know
pretty well and I think I might like her
a little bit more than her but I'm
worried about hurting my original
friend's feelings have you gonna need
advice for me about how I go about this
cheese well let's ask any buzz-buzz down
under let's ask your uh that's the
[ __ ] wife yeah Cat Cat what should he
do let's talk about your Australian
crush right now I think you should just
tell her because how does he know that
she actually likes him and isn't just
[ __ ] him
yeah no one's moving forward are they
yeah they're just [ __ ] hmm I'd have
to know how long he you know get up yeah
cat through this with it huh God cat
yeah thought you cared a little more
Gang Gang cut cut no very nice gentleman
yeah he does seem friendly I'd have to
know how long they've been bumping in
there grinding you know if it's a long
time at it offs ain't going nowhere so
[ __ ] the friend you know I'm saying
house nuts down under but if it's your
friend no not bus nuts down under
Brendan what's it looking like nine year
old has been watching too much
pornography dog or Derek yeah what I'm
saying is I think this guy you can't
just [ __ ] your friends friend all the
time man okay
why not because you're gonna lose your
friend maybe it's Australia yeah things
happen they're just like to happen
everywhere Brendan okay it's not a
mythical place in time they're not
actors so I think you have to try and
you got to talk to the friends hey what
are you
friend thing you know or let the sexual
situation with your first friend run out
before you take that opportunity before
you try the sign that's too long bro we
just tell the hot friend that you're
banging for all this time you know your
friend is hot we should include her see
what she says he's young yeah it's like
the movie you or the show you phoria
next thing you know you're doing drugs
you got eyeliner on your conten to do
you don't know there's techno but you're
down under that shows her tits I heard
it's horrible oh that's fantastic really
seems like you would like it yeah I do I
love it
yeah well you remind me don't watch it
then you remind me of the dad in it yeah
that's fine dude go watch it you're the
dad in it yeah fine
you're a buckle bunny I haven't seen it
well this guy should see it and he
should take notes from it and try and
[ __ ] both of them Derek what do you
think dude you've obviously ruined white
girls life by busting or constant my
friend yeah I agree
you should James Bond that [ __ ] let's
try to get both of them man you know all
you guys are disgusting discuss your
culture culture looks like Leo DiCaprio
down under
that's a fostering some tears make sure
you take care of your [ __ ] buddy friend
bro if you [ __ ] all your buddies then
you don't have any buddies dude you
never had a boomerang okay then he don't
give a [ __ ] whatever I'll do a threesome
with these chicks sometime by watch
Crocodile Dundee and [ __ ] both of them
yeah that's what I said
shout out to the Brisbane Lions brush
Dundee that hitter gang that hitter
don't even remember now that's a knife
no I don't remember that dude shout out
to shout out to somebody that's better
that's Australian that's more recent oh
shut who is Australian shout out
- uh-oh Thor Chris Hemsworth is
Australian shout out to Wolverines
Australian shout out to Gallipoli shout
out to Toni Kukoc oh is the Australian
Australian no dude new Croatian you
might be right on that yeah Longley
though is uh yeah shout out to Luc
Longley man oh shout to BJ Simmons is
the Australian really got the Kyrie
Irving also Australian no Ben Simmons
what I say but this Japanese Sixers yeah
and Simmons is Australian yeah he's also
seem like an egomaniac that didn't even
try in college when talking about
players not doing [ __ ] in college he
didn't tell us shoot for one season
that's how bad he was you don't even
[ __ ] remember it and they didn't even
make the n-c-double-a his bro cuz young
give a [ __ ] he's waiting for all the
millions well [ __ ] dude he's all-star
well then if he don't give a [ __ ] dude
then [ __ ] him bro that's what I'm saying
no well he's [ __ ] something it's
Kardashian let him do whatever he wants
bro you're hating on him dude he accused
him of being racist ill at a casino and
he's white well he's more white as we
are he's definitely more white than we
are
yeah he's Australian white yeah dude
that's double white yeah you're right
that's why they got a great white prom
down
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching